are you getting out of your old category
is my question because Nike and Adidas
was who you were focused on and we just
heard from the adidas CEO they could
sign between five and five hundred
athletes yes well spending what you just
chase one another there's no strategy
right and we're not gonna compete with
our dumbest competitor either so they
will chase they will chase the old they
will chase the old model and and we've
got good competitors in our space but we
also see some things that are better
rational from where we say so chasing
and bidding someone up is not the goal
the race to the bottom is not the goal
that we have so we think that in order
to spend our money you'll still see us
go after the right assets the
appropriate assets and we'll spend to
get those assets but then you also see
us take a different approach which we
think this is this is a different voice
a different communication a different
handshake with the Under Armour concern
but is adidas your dumbest competitor
specifically I I don't mind you quoting
me I didn't say it but I don't like them
no no I don't like them I don't like the
other guys either but that's my job